berenice la divinatrice iniziava antica
[Musica]
[Risate]
stiamo il libro ci ha portato qua in
questa campagna
ma che cosa significa forse vuol dire
che la prossima creatura la troveremo
qua in questa campagna
vi ricordate che abbiamo catturato le
altre creature grazie al libro il libro
si porta dalle creature
è sentito avete sentito alcun sala tir
prof
forse è meglio che ci incamminiamo non
siamo fermi a porta guardato capello
cosa dice vere inizio la divinatrice se
il tuo futuro vorrei svelare non
invitare ad entrare o no l'atp natrice
se il tuo futuro vorrei svelare non
esitare ad entrare una creatura che il
libro ci vuol far catturare
una creatura la divinatrice un po strano
forse lei ci dirà dove trovare la
prossima creatura perché lei svela il
futuro
che se è profumo dalla natura
[Musica]
stato momento con questo l'odore di cibo
ma insomma non è anzi va detto forse la
divinatrice sta cuocendo e sta cucinando
qualcosa ed e magari libro ci sta
proprio conducendoli per avere un pranzo
coi fiocchi non credo
andare a cibo adesso dobbiamo trovare la
creatura è come se ne avete il libro
sbrighiamo si stai a scoprire
i miti avanti care
mi aspetto con ansia
[Risate]
guarda il castello c'è anche qua non era
la giù il cappello forse ha messo più
cartelli perché pensava che altrimenti
ci saremmo persi e almeno sappiamo che
stiamo nella strada giusta dobbiamo
continuare andare di là a capo allora
chi ne ti devo tantissimo insieme i miei
cari
o brutto per voi un bellissimo giochino
vedrete ci divertiremo tanto
coraggio
coraggio claridi aspetto con ansia
non so perché ma un brutto presentimento
lavori perché dici così senti anche il
profumo del cibo momento
permetto di gela c'è nessuno
il fratello del re visione divinatrice e
lo stesso cartello che abbiamo trovato
fuori o vuol dire che siamo nel posto
giusto è qualla divinatrice qualche
libro voleva che il 22 non circuire
forse forse la vicinanza
con rotolo cibo controllo complice
qualcosa ma pace pur non è qui non credo
che sia una clessidra per di
cottura questa cristina potrebbe avere
un qualche incantesimo sopra è meglio
non toccare niente ok vediamo solo che
invece qua sotto
[Musica]
ok meglio non toccare niente ma forse lì
dentro c condisci all'insalata no è una
sfera di cristallo e con le sfere di
cristallo le divinatrice prevedono il
futuro credo io non ci credo a queste
cose nel remix sarà sicuramente lì a
preparare qualcosa da mangiare
lo senti che profumo soave che c'è qua
dentro e il libro ci ha portato fin qui
vuol dire che troveremo una creatura da
qualche parte quindi guardiamoci intorno
guarda secondo me il libro già portato
qua soprattutto mi ha portato qua pronto
per farmi assaporare questi odori sensi
che profumo di pietanze etnica
apcom erano partiti da dentro magari ci
fa proprio i fagioli questa giovane
sembra che faccia delle pozioni quadro
che dici quasi fanno i fagioli che sul
fuoco vicino donne un lavoro più aspetta
cerca qualcosa da mangiare il termine
non sta indicando niente qua vuol dire
che siamo nel posto giusto però non c'è
nessuno cosa dobbiamo fare è aspettare
forse siamo nel posto giusto ma un
momento sbagliato cerca qualche indizio
ok ok
è questa che cosa significa
guarda il sale rosa dell'himalaya una
buongustaia ha fatto per ora rimasta
invece qualcosa qua ha detto
renzo videsott indizio questo e un
cappello da strega forse non lo so
oppure un cappello ne andrete da un
cammello la tuba e un cappello non voi
non credo che sarò molto felice per
iniziati etica te con il suo cappello
addosso che è solo un cappello che cosa
vuoi che sia guarda posso fare anche il
pirata con questo il pirata vitale
per bari per i sette mari del mondo di
capo
sono arrivato
è questo che cosa secondo te a me sembra
una canoa di quello che cos'è questo
sembra sembra una marmitta il collettore
di una marmitta non lo so che cosa ci fa
con questa una bella di una strega non
credo che siano marmitta credo che sia
un qualche unico comunque un'idea nel
caso che benedice non fosse amichevole
utilizzeremo questo come arma che ne
pensi la canoa non è una canoa è una
maschera si presta dobbiamo cercare con
ricerche sulla creatura io ho tempo
questa come i romani di testa io cerco
qualcosa per difendermi
ma che stai facendo con quelle cose
stavo provando a suonare non lo so
magari con questa malattia la faccio la
facciamo apparirà berenice e se poi
succede qualcosa con questa le facce
elettrica sotto le ascelle
ma così si arrabbia ancora di più erano
ben che stavo scherzando
limite l'etologo della forfora della
spalla un'idea che idea s'è per farla
comparire dove siamo semplicemente
chiamarlo anzi prova a chiamarla tre
volte sono a questo strano strumento
vediamo cosa succede
berenice
belice
se fosse una cosa
che cosa c'è
detenuti cari e le dimore non c'è come
abbiamo nico accomodate e lei
bell'inizio sì sono io prego accomodati
tu saresti la divina ridere e sonda
povera vecchietta tanto tanto sola ogni
tanto mi diletto a leggeri futuro il
futuro c'è niente deve aver paura
secondo voi dovremmo fidarci libero
inizio la divinatrice dovremo farci
rendere il futuro forse possiamo fare
una domanda per capirlo e cioè così
signora berenice la divinatrice ma non è
che per caso ebbe che sta cucinando
queste
profumatissime prelibatezze sento un
motore magnifico sicari sto cucinando
una bellissima pizza o altre stagioni
il viaggio e poi tre stagioni non sta
dicendo posta per convincerti a farti
ridere il futuro ha fatto la pizza è che
appaia la vita di cd rom sono solo una
povera vicina come mai avete tanta paura
di me sono sempre tanto solo e triste
finalmente due ospiti che possa invitare
a cena io non mi fido tanto però forse è
l'unico modo per trovare la prossimo
creature il libro esso ha portato qua
dobbiamo per forza ascoltare questa
berenyi ascoltiamo lo darei point che
dopo sei sono pizza tanto di guadagnato
va bene se diamo
musicali di sapere che aveva una nomina
tanto carina e mi ha insegnato tanto
e così gli segnata leggere il futuro a
leggere il futuro si
possa fare una domanda
ma voi cosa state cercando
bella queste parti
non dirle niente potrebbe essere
pericoloso magari è proprio ai un acre
odore meglio non dire niente ma se la
facciamo allora glielo dicono che siamo
video preferito una jackie si si si ci
sarà anche la pizza ma secondo me prima
di lei col futuro non arrivi da qualche
indizio cosa state cercando
io sinceramente non credo che sia
possibile leggere il futuro secondo me
sei solo una ciarlatana
puoi anche non crederci a dita ma niente
può cambiare quello che è scritto nel
futuro aspetta un momento
vai a sapere il mio nome
[Musica]
o forse l'hai fatta arrabbiare
non abbiate timore che niente di cui
aver paura si si io vorrei sapere che
cosa mangiano questa sera quindi signora
be nice la divinatrice mi può vedere il
futuro quelli all igiene o il tuo futuro
si saprei anche quando morì quando
maggior hai letto della prossima fetta
di pizza o no effettuato papa detto
incerto che ha sentito quando mangia
nulla mio prossimo pezzo di pizza prima
ha detto quando mori e noi dobbiamo
fidarci di questa parigi andiamocene
perché dai e stiamo bene per mangiare
qualcosa magari può aiutarci a trovare
le creature prossima idea si sporchiamo
una nostro vantaggio e va bene berenice
dimmi pure quanto dice il mio futuro
mi chiamo gare sì ma dove sì sì facoltà
qualcosa di molto strano e vigoroso
pericoloso
dei vostri invidiato futuro
accadrà qualcosa di molto pericoloso
professor ventose di
aspettare di utile l'allievo napoli e
testate 19 aprile potete salvare le
diavole dovete rispettare le creature
dovete provare ma attenti a non farvi
trasformare 10 punti dovete pensare se
talora l'edizione vivi volete tornare
e se il tempo scadere parete in una
delle mie creature di trasporto
[Risate]
ma ci penso di no non ci sta inseguendo
[Musica]
detto che che cosa ha fatto i nostri
polsi così questo sarai anche tu lo so
fammi vedere
un marchio un segno un simbolo che cosa
vuol dire
[Risate]
ho paura che berenice la divina tris e
ciò abbia lanciato una maledizione è
pentito la filastrocca ti ha detto eto'o
non diamo adesso come facciamo a trovare
i dieci punti che cosa ci aspetterà
adesso ma voi avete lasciato un mi piace
mi raccomando cliccate mi piace qua
sotto e ora andiamo a consultare il
nostro libro storie paurose scuola di
misteri per vedere troviamo una tonaca
le abbiamo